hello world welcome to co playing honey
foxxx hit me played him for quite a
while I feel Austrian feeder master
here's a pretty nice setup I think
against the English it's an easy to play
and it has some some cool points yeah
one point is that each life is sometimes
an option probably not against the
knight on f3 ok so beef is sorry b4 b5
this is idea a4
okay no takes maybe it takes with the
sea pawn here that's possible currently
the night Hank so b7 is not on free then
I was wondering what you do here if I
should just play a move like c6 or if I
have something else I can also play d5
here by the way just completely opening
it up yeah why not I I think this could
be a good solution just making sure that
I'm not suffering the whole time from
that slightly weaker should be seven
porn ok it doesn't take so night c phi
this an idea for him yeah currently i
have this covered so i can still play a
move like that
what would you what foot what was
happening after f5 by the way could have
played at five okay then he had to play
III or something something wacky I
simply didn't think about this that the
night might have no squares it okay so
what's the deal here TR Queenie seven is
an easy move just covering c5
yeah five now it doesn't really make
much sense anyone sure plate that a bit
quicker he's got Roxy one jazz damn
light c5 taking d3 as a moose like goopy
80 really stupid moves him no let's 5i
can tag and the end take d 3 that was
the idea
let's it's probably not that bad for him
but also certainly not what he had in
mind okay an e-form is what wide wants
to play at this that's possible at him
then after night was I would lose one of
the pawns me okay okay maybe be six push
the route back Roxy six Bishop d7 as
good for me and then have before I think
so drops back yeah and again he's got
the c-4 move claw ahead why why because
of the time maybe Bishop before here Oh
Bishop before Brooke a three takes on 85
Bishop before winning winning stuff oh
my god
yeah but I'm not just making a drawing I
mean I'm used to being down on time
it's bit awkward
okay I'm to slow him
mmm I immediately okay that I didn't
take into account time morning hey
what's going on here have I miscounted
yeah it should be five he can take on f6
is the thing I'm losing this game
against this guy Adam don't believe Adam
Wow after you just blunder the phone for
the zip and pip just just for nothing
okay black resigns they just blonde at
this point for absolutely nothing so
yeah I mean okay I understand that maybe
he can draw because of the Big C porn
but losing for black is kind of kind of
idiotic yeah this already blundered
youtube you should be form saw that too
late so here we can he can do this take
take and stead h3 which I don't know
what is all about and five yeah right
here don't ship see fry already gets
tricky i have to probably play a move
like that now it's conductivity I mean
he really just wondered that poem but
sometimes they get compensation for
those pawns and here this is the case
it's not so not an easy we know anything
yeah it was really a bad game anyway I
mean I can go at five I mean somehow
someway I didn't have focus him he has
no square he has to go III and then I
don't know what's best no idea man this
is the engine suggestion which I don't
know don't like that much okay with
Queen deform abs hmm ah what a costly
game and I was so close to 2500 again
and then you lose some such a stupid
game anyway thanks for watching